- There's a spot.
- Naw, I couldn't fit in there.
It's way too tight, that one.
- No, you can make it, you're
a great parallel parker.
(ominous music)
- [Voiceover] Oh fuck!
(heavy bell chimes)
- [Waiter] And what can
I get for you today?
- [Woman] I'll have the brussel
sprout and fried egg salad.
- Excellent and for you sir?
- I'll have the swordfish.
- [Waiter] We actually just
ran out of the swordfish.
Is there something else I can get for you?
(ominous music)
- [Internal monologue] Yeah,
yeah, find something ...
I'll find something, steak, red meat,
can't do red meat, too much
cholesterol, I'm watching that.
I need fish, fish, fish,
fish, fish, fish, fish.
Find something, oh dear
God, help me find something.
Help me! Help me! Help me!
(light piano music)
- (blowing sigh)
(women chatting)
- Hey!
(woman laughs)
- [Internal Monologue] Oh my God!
They're laughing at me!
- I'm trying, I can't...
(horn honking)
the machine's broke.
(horn honking angrily)
It's not taking it.
(multiple horns honking)
It's not taking it, it's not
my fault it's not taking it!
(ominous music)
- Oh you know what, this
is not what I ordered.
Do you mind getting
the waiter's attention?
(panicked music)
- [Woman] Hey, Andy, um boss says
she's looking for you, so...
(ominous music)
(sniffles)
(metal tap clicks)
(panicked music)
- How much you wanna leave for a tip?
(phone vibration)
(ominous music)
- Mmepphh
- Yeah, I was reading this weekend
that if California keeps
up in this drought,
two years we'll be out of water.
- It's the price we pay
for living in a desert.
- Yeah.
Oh, your fly's open.
(panicked music)